[Applause]
the moose
is back mike moustakis in uni
in the lineup things are looking good
for the cincinnati rig
wade miley last time out 11 groundouts
induced against the mets
jonathan india on the fly key brian
hayes nestled in his familiar two-hole
chopped left side mustache is challenged
early he throws bounces past bottom
looked like hayes might have turned
slightly towards second but
able to scurry back to the bag and you
know the old baseball adage it will
find you if you're in there defensively
first play
certainly a challenge good throw
probably safe at first base anyway
it's in the batter's brian reynolds weak
wave at a miss
we don't often see those flailing swings
like that against my
bottom of the first inning and the reds
come to bound against jt brubacher
tonight game two of the four game series
176 era and three career starts against
the reds
one gone and now jesse winker jesse
winker cranks it
to deep right center field off the base
of the wall
winker rips up to second base is
standing double
with one out brubacher will have to
pitch with the man in scoring position
castellanos breaking ball ground ball
backhanded by key brian hayes throws to
first high
and pulls nakowski off the bag and
hayes really took time to set up to get
a throw
off it would have been bang bang even if
the throw were accurate
first and second and that will be an
error so a double an
error by hayes and now a walk to the
bases are loaded
and that will bring mike mustaches to
the plate playing in his first game
since may 18th
wasted
[Applause]
well welcome back moose brubacher not
able to throw a strike with his first
two pitches
so moose is not just sitting on a
fastball he's sitting on a ball
over the plate where he could drive and
got that with the hanging slider
welcome back moose the reds poised for
more
one out kyle farmer farmer
shallow left center splashes on down
follow scores
mustache green light then conceded along
to second
moose crosses the plate two run poked by
farmer and a four-run reds lead
in the opening inning a walk to tyler
and aquin farmer up to second base
two on for tucker barnhart
a three run homer for tucker barnhart
seven nothing reds it's their most in an
opening inning since september of 04
against the pirates milanko as a board
brings up rodolfo castro
there's the ground ball left side
mustache has it kick off his glove
farmer has it to second and they get the
out there
what a great job by farmer to feel the
deflection off of the heel of mustaches
glove
and the presence of mind knowing he had
the time to feed india at the bag
to get the out the reds own a seven to
nothing lead as they bat in the second
inning jesse winker said to lead things
off
he swings and he drives this to left
center field this time and very deep
and gone just over the 379 sign
jesse winker with his 22nd home run of
the year
to tyvato and suarez for the team lead
now eight nothing reds nightmare
continues for j.t
brubaker mike mustakis a two-run double
mustache rips it to right polanco can't
track it down
and overruns it mustacha scoots up to
second
welcome back mike moustakis is
two for two with a pair of doubles
now kyle farmer base hit for farmer
drove home two and his first at bat
that hanger looked to left house
windmill mustache head first plunge
nine nothing elevated slider doesn't do
much of anything
that's summer olympics worthy yeah that
might become a new a new event this is
the moment near the end of the party
when the guy who hadn't been there in a
while just goes full-on belly flop in
the pool
stallings lined out second baseman
jonathan india his first time up against
the lefty miley who's ready to go
wade miley gets his swing and miss from
jacob stallings that is the second
strikeout
for miley tonight gregory polanco will
come to the plate
another swing of the miss back to back
miley case
he's popping that one that's a good
fastball you see wade doesn't get to see
the left-handers too often so these are
the fans in their green clad
shirts the official gear the swag of the
wade miley fan club it's a thing
one on one out here is gregory polunko
polanco double play ball farmer hits the
bag
overhead throw in time double play
miley faces the minimum a nine nothing
shutout now back to the top of the order
jonathan india bats he is o for three in
this game
and india has been one of the red's
hottest hitters
boom goes
five homers in his last seven games
that's the 26th home run by the reds
from the lead off position in the order
only toronto and atlanta
have had more this year pulling out the
boom stick
in miley's game it's the sixth time this
year the reds have scored double-digit
runs at a mindly start
time for the second most for a red
starting pitcher since 1900
colin moran just activated today tapper
back to the mound miley turns
throws to second farmer to first that's
a double play
one six three and that will end the
pirates
seven mike mustackas who's two for three
to the gap in right center down to the
wall
mustache zips up to second base his
first game back in almost three months
it's three doubles for the moose he is
the first red
to post three doubles in one game since
jose perazo
august 15th of 2018 10 run lead and sean
doolittle
is on here in the night strike three
call
little coming out throwing that
four-seamer
perfectly located and that is 500
career strikeouts for sean doolittle
and there is 501 back-to-back case for
doolittle
pirates have not had a double-digit
shutout defeat against the reds since
1966.
line to center caught by
naked a 10 nothing
blowout means 10 straight
home wins for the cincinnati reds
against the pittsburgh pirates it's
their longest streak in nearly
decades of domination against pittsburgh